لا يثير مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد في
فرنسا حنق الطبقه العامله فقط روميل دا
كوستا وهاجر الطاهري طالبان خرج للتظاهر
مدفوعين بهواجس الضرر الذي قد يلحق بهما
مستقبلا من وراء اقراره
المشروع فانه سيفتح الباب لاصلاحات اكثر
ليبراليه قد يكون ضررها علينا اكبر لذا
علينا ان ننزل جميعا الى الشارع ونعبر عن
غضبنا وبالمعنى الادق علينا ان نثور
يؤاخذ جمهور الطلبه المحتجين الحكومه على
ما يعتبرونه تازيما للوضع الاجتماعي في
البلاد وتمسكا بفرض قانون يتوقعون له
تداعيات وخيمه على مختلف فئات المجتمع
ورفع المتظاهرون شعارات تتهم الحكومه
بالتضحيه بفئه الشباب واخرى تصيمها
بالعماله لراس المال على حساب ما تصفه
بالشعب الكادح وتنبه الى عطل اصاب الديمق
راطيه الفرنسيه
وبعيدا عن ساحات الغضب يمضي مجلس شيوخه في
فحص مشروع القانون الم للجدل مقرا للبندا
السابع المتعلقه برفع سن الخروج الى
التقاعد الى الرابعه وستين
لم تواجه الاغلبيه اليمينيه في مجلس
الشيوخ مشاكل كتلك التي واجهتها الكتله
ذاتها في مجلس النواب في التصديق على
البند السابع من المشروع فان المعارضه
اليساريه تعتبرت ما تم تمريره اجراء لا
انسانيا يدفع فاتورته الفقراء لفائده
الاثرياء
لا رحمه في قلوبكم انتم تائهون في
حساباتكم التقنيه ولكني اؤكد انكم اهملتم
الجانب الانساني تماما انتم مثل روبن
ديبوا غير انكم تاخذون مال الفقراء لتردوه
على الاغنياء
اتهامات المعارضه للحزب الحاكم طالت وصمه
باخضاع السلطه التشريعيه بالكامل للسلطه
التنفيذيه بما يضعف النموذج الديمقراطي
الفرنسيه برمته لطفي المسعودي الجزيره
باريس